our next guest is a very very dear
friend of the show and guru of green
living and sustainability he's the
editor-in-chief of naturally danny ceo
danny i love you it's danny ceo
everybody everyone
i love it
this show
has changed my life i love this show
ever you know for me it's new york city
9 a.m i watch the whole hour every
morning with a cup of coffee
and something i think you all could
watch for the cup of coffee also is with
this recipe that we're gonna make
together too let's do it danny i'm in
your passenger seat you're the driver it
is
completely gluten-free it's plant-based
this is a broccoli creamy polenta spoon
bread oh gosh it's comforting but again
gluten-free plant-based and you can make
it all in the blender which is so
amazing so
um we're gonna put in um like a
dairy-free milk so this is coconut milk
but you can do almond milk you could do
whatever you want but the coconut milk
has that extra fat in it which is really
nice it does and then these are our dry
ingredients we've got nutritional yeast
that's the cheesiness oat flour garlic
powder baking powder
salt you know it's all very just simple
things you can find and we're just going
to carefully put this all in the blender
guys like you know so it's not messy
so we'll take this beautiful blender and
i'm just going to turn it on
and then we're going to liquefy it
danny what consistency should it be
should it be truly liquefied
consistency pancake batter consistency
this is perfect oh this is absolutely
perfect
so we're gonna we're gonna leave it in
our blender for now and we're gonna do
one more thing drew
this is do you like miso paste i
love
miso is this a white or a red this is a
white it doesn't matter what you have
you can find this in the refrigerated
section at your supermarket a little bit
of miso paste and in the bowl we have
grated sweet potato
and what we're going to do is massage
this is carrot sweet potato
sweet potato for fiber and flavor and
we're going to mix it together what's
happening is that the natural saltiness
of the miso it's breaking down the
toughness
of the sweet potato so you're massaging
it in to make it soft and tender so that
you still have those pieces of sweet
potato and the spoon bread but it's not
going to be tough it's going to bake all
the way through
so we're going to pour our our liquid
right into the bowl just like this
combine all of our ingredients together
and guys that's itch
can you believe that it's so easy to
make and what you do
is in a large cast iron pan like this
you want to grease it with like a high
heat oil so avocado oil coconut oil i
love avocado oil okay so in your cast
iron pan guys it's been grease all you
do is pour it all the way in
and if you notice
i said this is broccoli right so we're
missing the broccoli we're going to
scrape it all in i want to get it all
into
our casserole and pan i am the biggest
broccoli fan
food i grew up vegetarian my mom and i
lived in california in the 1970s and you
know we were like the total cliche
um
and um
of that kind of hippie era stuff
actually we were so not uh we were so
many odd
you don't want to mix it up
oops
it's going to be delicious
but what you want you want the broccoli
to um like cook
and be floating on top
and we are we're just going to put the
pretty broccoli on top
[Applause]
and a really nice pattern
like that you see that
yeah i'm on it
oh and they're they're frozen they're
frozen on purpose so this is something
where you don't need fresh broccoli
frozen broccoli is actually just as
fresh all the nutrients are locked in
and what it does it helps to keep its
shape
and it's
beautiful
i mean that's what women you know
like come off like on a cooking demo
like you know i'm just casual and i'm
placing my broccoli i only know like
lucille ball style i'm like oh my god oh
my god
and i love to cook
listen it's still going to be delicious
but this is also a way of making it just
sort of like a beautiful one-dish meal
it goes into the oven at 375 degrees for
about 50 minutes to an hour 15 minutes
it's crispy coming across from the edges
but you want it to be not dry it's going
to be a spoon bread so it's a little bit
moist and wet and it's
perfect whenever you just want like a
food that hugs you can i have a bite yes
oh my gosh it's right here guys and it's
so good with like a little dollop of
yogurt serving warm and salivating
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
um
savory very moist cheesy
yeah and it's in the winner issue of my
magazine you can get the recipe for this
or just go to the drewberry merchant
so drew i have a question for you
about a cast iron pan you know one of
the things that we love a cast iron but
we don't like
the heat that it holds which is great
but also it can scorch your countertop
and also can be hard to hold so i want
to show you a really great diy
okay i'm in i learned so much from you
danny
so
we're gonna learn a diy how to make
we're gonna make something to protect
your hands but also to protect
your countertops too that's a little
sneak peek okay well i think we're going
to go to a quick commercial break and
then we're going to learn this amazing
hack and tip from danny because
it doesn't stop at food it's everything
this is a whole lifestyle that he
presents that's why he's changed my life
[Music]